was für ein teurer montag denn die
bundesregierung hat jetzt festgelegt wie
hoch die gas umlage wird also der
aufschlag der nochmal auf den sowieso
schon so stark steigenden gaspreis oben
drauf kommt 24 19 cent das ist die
gasanlage wir wollen uns das jetzt noch
mal genauer anschauen also kein die
frage geht ein dich was kostet uns diese
gas umlage pro jahr tatsächlich ja aber
einen tiger lasst uns drauf schauen hier
hinter mir auf diese teuer zahlen von
diesem montag also 2,4 cent das haben
wir alle gehört das soll jetzt also die
gasanlage werden und das bedeutet das
fürs portemonnaie hier je nachdem mit
wie viele menschen sie im haushalt leben
fangen wir an hier bei der familie mit
zwei kindern also ganz normales
576 euro kommen hier daraufhin ganz
normalen vier-personen-haushalt
576 euro in der wohnung mit 160 170
quadratmetern ungefähr also dass die
gasanlage aufs ganze jahr gerechnet wir
haben das auch für paare natürlich
ausgerechnet da kommen gut 300 euro 350
euro obendrauf durch diesen politischen
beschluss jetzt und in einem
singlehaushalt ungefähr 150 euro 140
euro also das was je nachdem wie groß
ihre wohnung ist wie viel sie heizen im
moment noch oben drauf kommt für sie auf
den ohnehin schon so hohen gaspreis dass
durch diese 2,4 cent gas umlage heute
also bekannt gegeben heute offiziell
beschlossen durch die bundesregierung
ganz ganz winziger hoffnungsschimmer
steckt noch drin nämlich was wird
eigentlich hier raus aus der
mehrwertsteuer die ist hier eingerechnet
es gibt aber noch politischen
diskussionen in welcher höhe die
mehrwertsteuer auf die gas umlage erhöht
erhoben wird und ob sie möglicherweise
noch komplett wegfällt also schauen wir
einmal auf die tabelle aus der wir dann
diese mehrwertsteuer noch einmal raus
gerechnet haben immer noch sehr sehr
viel geld für einen singlehaushalt 120
euro gut obendrauf für ein paar haushalt
knapp 300 euro obendrauf und für eine
familie mit zwei kindern also den vier
personen haushalt gut 480 euro gas
umlage obendrauf das sind schlimme
zahlen heute an diesem super teuer
montag die gasanlage die auf 2,4 cent
pro kilowattstunde erhoben wird ab
november zahlen alle gaskunden das in
deutschland darüber wollen wir jetzt
sprechen und zwar mit julia klöckner der
wirtschaftspolitischen sprecherin der
unionsfraktion im bundestag alle frau
klöckner 100 euro kommen also jetzt
obendrauf noch mal für familien das ist
sowieso ohnehin schon schwer zu stemmen
für normalverdienende familie und
normalverdiener wie viele deutsche wird
diese umlage jetzt machen
jeder wird zu knapsen haben wir sind die
allermeisten auch der mittelstand also
wirklich der mittelstand der auf kante
genäht ist also auch haushalte auch wenn
sie doppelverdiener sind aber mit
mehreren köpfen in einer familie wir
haben es gerade gesehen sind rund 500
euro 400 euro wirklich hab ich weil man
damit eben nicht gerechnet hat und das
schlimmste ist so was hinzukommt ist
dass die bundesregierung zwar schnell
eine belastung beschlossen hat für die
bürgerinnen und bürger aber die
entlastung stichwort kalte progression
steuern und abgaben auf energie kosten
runter da es sich die ampel noch nicht
einig und sie hat auch vergessen im
übrigen vorher zu klären ob die
mehrwertsteuer wegfallen kann und
deshalb ist diese art der umlage auch
falsch gestrickt worden das heißt am
ende belastungen für bürger aber an
ihrer entlastung gerade nicht gedacht
das halte ich für sehr stressig frau
klöckner konkret jetzt aber was schätzen
sie wie viele deutsche tatsächlich
prozentual wird das jetzt machen und vor
sehr sehr große wirtschaftliche probleme
stellen
das ist eine nette frage von ihnen aber
sie müssen erst definieren was sie
unterarm verstehen und wie soll ich
prozentual etwas schätzen denn sind ja
einige unbekannte noch die unbekannten
sind zum beispiel erstens nochmal
definition am 2 wie viele köpfe ein
haushalt hat was wirklich auf einen
haushalt zukunft und drittens fällt die
mehrwertsteuer wird ja oder nein und
viertens das ist auch noch nicht geklärt
welche auswirkungen hätte ein ausgleich
der kalten progression zum beispiel und
bessert sind bringt er solche
schätzungen überhaupt nichts wie viel
prozent an interessiert jeden haushalt
was heißt es für ihn selbst und nicht
für die anderen prozent der nachbarn
dann bleiben wir bei der mehrwertsteuer
frau klöckner sehen sie noch chancen
wird dass wenigstens die mehrwertsteuer
wegfällt das macht ja auch noch mal satt
was aus wie haben es gerade an den
zahlen gesehen also schocknachricht für
heute und dann vielleicht noch ein ganz
bisschen hoffnung dass wenigstens die
mehrwertsteuer nicht erhoben werden muss
auf die gasanlage sind sie dann chance
am ende wird das brüssel entscheiden
müssen aber ich halte es für wirklich
fahrlässig wie die bundesregierung die
amten regierung hier vorgegangen ist sie
wollte das ist ganz ganz schnell geht
stichwort umlage die die bürger
erbringen müssen aber sie hat vergessen
vorher zu klären ob brüssel quasi 1 1
gibt man hätte im übrigen die fachleute
sagen diese gasanlage auch anders
stricken können da müsste man ja sehr
ins detail gehen damit eben die
mehrwertsteuer darauf nicht anfallen
würde das ist also schnelligkeit gegen
der ampel vor gründlichkeit und das
müssen dann jetzt wohl auch die
bürgerinnen und bürger aus baden und das
ist nicht gut
dass wir jetzt diese preise hahn frau
klöckner ist das tatsächlich nur die
schuld von putin oder auch die schuld
der alten regierung die sich so abhängig
gemacht hat von putin
schuldfragen sind immer schön aber ich
glaube bisschen differenzieren müssen
wir schon rangehen wir haben alle davon
profitiert dass die energiepreise dh die
gaspreise recht günstig waren und jetzt
kommt ja noch einiges hinzu als
stichwort wir haben auch ein
stromproblem denn wenn die jetzige
bundesregierung nicht bereit ist
ziemlich schnell jetzt zu entscheiden
dass die verbliebenen akw also
kernkraftwerke in deutschland noch am
netz bleiben und strom kostengünstig
klimaneutral erzeugen können und wir
eben nicht weiter gas noch verstromen
müssen dann hätte das auch eine
entlastungswirkung der zweite punkt ist
sehr sehr klar hausgemacht in der
jetzigen zeit so hohe abgaben und
steuern auf energie zu haben halten wir
für falsch wir können als bundesrepublik
deutschland gerade in dieser situation
jetzt genau diese einnahmen daraus
senken der staat verdient gerade massiv
mit bei dieser inflation zehn milliarden
euro inflations punkt das halte ich für
unanständig der staat muss das geld sehr
umgehend an die bürger zurückgegeben und
selbst auch zurückschrauben denn er ist
ja mit auch inflationstreiber dadurch
eine frage zum schluss frau klöckner wir
denken noch einmal an die die wenig geld
verdienen die jeden tag arbeiten gehen
und trotzdem wenig haben wenn man in der
pflege arbeitet erzieherin ist wenn man
lkw fahrer ist handwerker und so weiter
und so fort und dann guckt man auf die
die hartz4 empfangen und die die nicht
sparen müssen im moment nicht unbedingt
energie sparen müssen weil sie die
kosten übernommen bekommen entsteht da
zunehmend eine ungerechtigkeit im land
die gefahr besteht dass ein ein gefühl
das nicht gerecht behandelt sein da es
strom oder energie zu sparen muss sich
lohnen und zwar für jeden muss ich das
lohn und deshalb müssen die anreize auch
starker sein wer energie einspart wir
sehen aber mal ein klick auf die
unternehmen über die sollten wir hier
auch reden über die haben wir noch gar
nicht gesprochen das sind die
arbeitgeber
die letztlich wettbewerbsfähig bleiben
müssen und das ist auch eine soziale
frage weil es hier um gefährdung von
arbeitsplätzen geht kurz um energie
sparen muss sich lohnt dafür müsse es
stärkere anreize durch die
bundesregierung geben
[Musik]